whatever anybody believes out there i
see something as an elder in this
community that is not right it's off
it's hurting not only the community but
it's hurting a bunch of people who
should never be in this space and it's
inappropriate for our community to keep
pushing this narrative as if anyone can
be trans because that's not true
hi i'm buck angel i am a transsexual man
which means i was born female i'm a
biological female it's a difficult space
because today we have all this weird
narrative going on but you know i just
felt like a boy i just always stayed you
know since i was a little kid and you
know i was a tomboy on some level but
that being said i grew up as a female
and then eventually i realized i could
have what we used to call a sex change
and i
i did a situation where i took hormones
and i was one of the very first people
to do that here in los angeles 30 i did
this 30 years ago you know i come from a
very medicalized space i come from a
space called gender dysphoria which is a
which is a diagnosis a mental
disorder that i have that i've had my
whole life where i feel like the
opposite gender now we have trans with
no gender dysphoria no need for it to be
a disorder no need for mental health
care self id
affirmation therapy come on that says to
me on some level some form of
indoctrination it's like anyone can be
trans join the party and i'm i'm like
wait
i would have chosen to been a born a
male over anything you see right here
but i didn't get born i wasn't born male
so now i had to fix it by doing all this
that's what i want to want these kids to
see i also want the world to see this
isn't a game and it's not something i
can pick or choose i want to be trans
and today i am and tomorrow i not once
you choose this life and do this what i
did there really is no turning back
that's why it's important we understand
i do think somehow some people are being
told they're trans when they're not
i see a vast huge desire to
fast track for a lack of a better you
know term
these children into this space of trans
kids and put them on something that
they're calling puberty blockers
this could be a very dangerous space and
it is a dangerous space we are pushing
because we're giving drugs to children
to stop puberty so i personally believe
blocking puberty could be disastrous now
that being said i do believe there might
be some children because i've witnessed
it that could possibly benefit from this
but it's very few and far it is not the
amount of kids that are immediately
being put on blockers with no mental
health care no desire to sort of watch
this kid kind of find their space but
it's like the kid says they're trans
they're trans there's no pushing back
this is this new affirmative therapy
there's no pushing back my parents did
what
we call today social transitioning where
they dress me you know i got to dress
like a boy it made me happy i was always
the little buck and but my parents
didn't put me on puberty blockers and my
dad actually said i would have never
done that he thought we thought you
would he said we thought you would grow
out of it but you didn't and look at you
today so of course i went through some
turmoil as a youngster of course all
youngsters go through turmoil and i'll
be honest i don't necessarily think some
form of turmoil or some form of you know
struggling whatever you want to call it
is a bad thing i i don't think so
depending on how high that struggle is i
i just the dishonesty is growing every
day growing every day and when you start
seeing the kids sort of repeat the
mantra of all of this stuff right trans
women are women trans men or men uterus
havers you know period people all of
these things that are so first off
disrespectful to to the woman's space
and secondly disrespectful to us we i am
not a biological man i never will be i'm
very honest about that and and it's why
the world is accepting of me because i
don't need to lie to you and so why are
we teaching kids to lie there's this
this idea that we have to lie to the
world in order for us to get our our
stuff no you don't i don't have to lie
to the world look at me i never had to
lie to the world and i did it before any
of this stuff happened it just says to
me something's wrong because you're not
appreciating what you have and instead
you're being very entitled and saying i
deserve this give this to me get out of
my way that is not
trans at all that is something else and
and it's actually scary for me to see
the attitudes coming out of this
community
you